606 on your tuesday morning one of the
state's biggest blood service providers
has a blood emergency the supply is down
about half this is the non-profit by
talent our candace charles is live at
the donor center on charleston just west
of rainbow with how you can help turn
those numbers around candace
good morning good morning folks yes they
really need you guys right now it really
is as simple as getting the prick you
can get something in return besides
helping save lives but right now i'm
going to tell you about the lives that
you can save we're talking about folks
in the community guys i'm joined by
brittany australia now i know that you
have seen that the people first hand
that folks are helping what are some of
their stories that's right you know
there is a specific hospital patient um
that i got to sit with recently her name
is rona she's a sickle cell patient in
our community you know every month she
receives eight units of type o positive
which means eight donors came to save
her life and right now we have a one day
supply of o positive remaining in our
community so if you know that you're all
positive we encourage you to come down
and donate with my talent as soon as
possible to help patients like rona and
the many hospital patients who need it
in the trauma centers cancer and
leukemia patients you know mothers
experiencing birthing complications or
premature babies you know there are so
many people that need a blood donation
during the shortage awesome awesome okay
i know you guys are trying to fill up
these seats and you guys have a way of
doing that with a great incentive thanks
so much brittany for coming in chatting
with us this morning that incentive is a
gas car guys you guys can win a chance
to get gas for the entire year by coming
down here to donate find out more
details as well as eligibility
requirements on
vitality.org for now i'm kansas charles
8 news now